Thank you so much for being here.
It's so awesome to have you back at Google.
Um,
and we're psyched to just hear what you have to say.
Thank you,
Jesse.
I'm thrilled to be back.
You guys hear me okay in the back there.
Um,
for anyone who's watching the video,
I'm told this room seats 900,
it's almost full.
So this is really,
this is great.
Uh,
so quickly,
um,
I'm not licensed to do this.
So as first it's probably a disclaimer,
but Kate and Jesse invited me to come speak at an offsite here four or five or
six months ago now.
But I've heard from a number of folks since sue wanted to connect.
And so,
so we came back,
uh,
I'm excited to do it.
Um,
I'm gonna walk you through essentially today a roadmap for,
you know,
thinking about your life and making a plan for your life,
which I can't emphasize enough.
I'm completely unqualified to do,
but at the same time I have found it useful.
Um,
people who are important to me have found it useful and you might as well,
we've got 60 minutes.
I have more so as as folks,
if you have to leave,
leave anytime.
Of course.
And I'll stay after a little while.
I didn't invite questions throughout and we're going to save time for questions
at the end.
Sound good?
Good plan for today.
All right.
First I need,
um,
I need two volunteers to help.
Just,
it's wonderful.
You didn't even know what I was going to ask for.
It could be anything.
Just tell me why you came,
what you were hoping to get out of today.
Uh,
so I have Jesse and I like to listen to her advice.
It's always good to get it out.
Take your second part
outside perspective and advice.
Anyone else?
Tell me just your goal for today.
I want to make sure we achieve it.
Anyone else?
What would you like to get out of today
again?
Okay,
so talking about the cloud was not in the original scope of the presentation,
but like,
I'm here for you guys.
So outside,
outside advice and perspective and talk about cloud.
What?
Oh,
so all right.
That's what we're gonna do.
Um,
thank you Kate.
Thank you Jesse for the invitation.
Thank you Alan and Matthew for getting this all set up.
What I want to do first is a quick exercise.
I'm going to ask you,
close your eyes.
You got,
I'm going to ask you to admit something for Matthew.
I would like you to put your hand in front of the camera.
You get a cover the camera,
and I want you to raise your hand if you are living the life and career that you
dreamed you'd be living.
If you are on your dream life's path,
raise your hand.
Okay,
good.
Both of you.
Put your hands down.
I've been there.
I know exactly.
I know exactly how you feel are one more thing.
Raise your hand if you are engaged or married and of bearing years.
Raise your hand.
All right.
Uh,
download the knot and the bumps.
That's what I do for it.
That's what I do for a living and I would appreciate that.
So here's how
there's a website that I want to tell you about.
And,
and,
and I,
I'll,
I'll give a footnote this with a friend of mine calls this,
this discussion,
my,
my self important obsession with my own mortality,
but I want you to play along and there's a website called [inaudible] dot com if
you put some information into death clock.com take care of yourself.
Do you smoke when you born?
It'll tell you,
give or take when you're going to die.
Now it doesn't know,
but it's from an actuarial table.
It gives you a bit,
it might be right,
it might be wrong.
Mine's May,
2068 all right,
so we've got a deadline and we've got,
now I work out,
I avoid third world airlines,
but still like there's a limited amount of time.
You have a limited amount of time and you,
you and I,
we sit in this incredibly privileged position in the context of the history of
the world.
The vast majority of human beings who have ever lived have the very short
British lives and spent most of their energy trying to have food,
shelter,
and to defend themselves.
Right?
Like that was most people's obsessions.
I have a friend who,
I mean even our,
most of us in this room,
our grandparents worked to make sure no one starved.
That was the purpose of work and then I get to be in a room with,
with folks like this who all were the smartest kids in their classes,
went to good colleges,
work at Google.
Someone made a movie about what it takes to try to get a job at Google and you
have one.
We're so fortunate.
Our lives are such a gift
and yet many of us,
especially those who come to obscure tech talks about planning your life,
feel this,
this dissatisfaction,
they we feel this thing,
something is not quite right.
We all have the sense that we have a limited amount of time and we have this
sense that we're blessed with something really precious amount of time and a
really precious opportunity and we're constantly wondering if we're doing the
right thing with it.
Also,
people like us have so many options,
so many options.
Headhunters call you guys,
they'd probably call you a lot and being recruited by other companies.
You can really do anything.
You work here,
you could do anything.
And there was a study done once.
Some weird psychologists had people walk into a store and there were four
jellies on the shelf and they calculated how many jellies they bought.
And then people would walk into the store and they put like 70 jellies on the
shelf and he calculated how many jellies people bought in.
The more jelly on the shelf,
the fewer people bought.
We're paralyzed by the array of choices that we have.
So I'm going to walk you through a little bit about how I think about I've,
how I've thought about those choices and some other folks have found those
choices in a way that other folks have found is useful.
A useful way to think about this choice.
So I'm going to skip some swag to go back to the beginning.
Uh,
any presentation that starts with a definition of a word is the worst
presentation.
But I'm sorry I did this last night for you.
Um,
what's important now,
that word,
there are multiple definitions.
I picked one.
One definition is of high status.
I like this.
One of great significance or value likely to have a profound effect on success,
survival or wellbeing important.
And we put that in context.
The,
I'd ask you a question,
how important are you?
No,
you could say,
well,
we're all unique and beautiful snowflake were all really important.
That's fair.
But like Mark Zuckerberg is more important than me.
I'm willing to admit that he's a very big on me.
How important are you?
There's an exercise that I've done,
uh,
and then others have found helpful then I'm going to walk you through now,
but the answers in a way,
this question,
so I'll start with you.
How important are you?
This is you,
I don't think about the impact that your life has.
Good,
honest assessment of the impact that your life has.
I,
um,
I first did this,
I was like 26 years old and I had this very prestigious job at a big media
company,
uh,
where I worked in corporate development and strategy and we met with important
people.
And you will.
I really,
I've was very big in my britches and a friend of mine was a kindergarten teacher
and she asked me to speak at the kindergarten for a employment day for jobs day.
And a little girl,
she was a kindergartener or a first grader,
came up and said to me,
they had these prepared questions they had asked you in the first one.
She said,
do you bring your lunch to work?
And I was like,
no,
that's a good idea.
I spent a lot of money on lunch.
I should bring my lunch to work.
Thank you.
And the second thing she said,
she said,
um,
do you work in New York City?
I said,
I do.
I work at Rockefeller Plaza.
It's really great.
Thank you for your questions for of course.
She said,
is your job important?
I said,
well,
I'm a capital allocation is an important lever of the success of a corporate
entity.
Um,
and you know,
I guess the strategy stuff is sometimes it's obvious,
but you know,
someone has to do these jobs and I am going to make a lot of charts.
And this little girl's looking at me and then she said,
I'm supposed to write yes or no,
and I said no.
And I had an existential crisis from a kindergarten and I went home and I did
this thing.
So I was like,
what am I important?
What do I do?
Well there's me and then what things do I touch on the world?
I think it was my family and friends and those of you who know me know I have
like six friends.
So there's that.
Um,
I called my parents but I've been,
this is not,
okay,
fine.
That's,
that's nice.
My,
when I described my work,
the sort of the word,
my value over replacement player just wasn't that high.
And the impact that I felt that I was having on the world wasn't that inspiring.
I did a little bit of like community service stuff and nothing where we've,
you took me out of the equation.
Something bad happens in the world.
Like I just,
I did the math and I was like,
cheese,
no wonder a little kid made me feel so bad.
I'm not having a big enough impact on the,
on the world with what I would argue is a pretty precious opportunity.
Sounds depressing.
And I said,
but,
and this is unfair.
So that exercise is unfair because I was,
I'm like,
I'm 26 you're 36 you get a lot of years to go and maybe you're on the right path
and you're going to have a huge impact.
Just haven't yet.
So did the,
did the exercise again and said,
oh,
when I called it,
this is the impact map.
I named this for you.
Okay.
So the next thing it's like,
all right,
imagine I become much more senior in my role.
I get my boss's boss's boss's job.
Then how much impact can I have?
And I sort of went through it and these are personal judgements.
So there,
there is no right answer here.
It's what you think is impactful.
I worked at a company whose primary KPI was the number of hours people spend on
their bud watching television.
So I was like,
even if I get to be a lot more important to this company,
I don't know that I'm necessarily having the impact that I want to have on the
world.
So I do my map
and I thought through things that I could be doing and if I'm more senior,
if I had more money,
if I had more time,
but it sort of scoped it out and I started coming to this conclusion.
I was like,
I don't know that I like the next 15 years that are laid up for me.
All right,
well this sucks and did it again.
I did a total zero based my life.
It was like you're smart young guy,
you got plenty of time ahead of you.
If you can do anything and presume for the second you can do anything,
how much impact did I have?
And in this was a hard exercise.
I literally at one point,
this is a true story.
I literally called NASA and asked what you have to do to be an astronaut?
And I got the time.
I was thinking like spaces so important.
But there's so there's nobody out in front like really pushing new frontiers.
It's,
but you have to be a pilot.
FYI.
If any of you,
if this is on your list and as you sort of run the math,
you're like,
all right,
like I could do that.
But that might not be the shortest point between shortest distance between two
points.
This part of the exercise of his will reveal to you.
I think whether or not you're currently executing a plan that is going to get
you to a place where you can have a big impact with your life.
So there was,
there's you and what you're achieving,
but I was achieving then what you might consider your achieving today.
Cause you a little bit more senior 10 years from now running the same playbook
and then there's blank space,
whatever.
You could do anything.
Now here I'll pause to say on this third exercise you have to suspend disbelief.
There's this thing that nags at all of us were like,
well I know I'm smart.
I hope I did well in school,
but I mean,
I don't know that I could fill in the blank down to company,
run a big company,
run for office,
write a book,
whatever your thing is.
I don't know.
There are people who do that.
I'm not that person.
And I've,
I,
I've had the pleasure of meeting all those people on the other side of it.
They're no smarter than you.
They don't know anything that you don't know.
There are two categories of people who have a job that you can't have,
like super superstar musicians and super superstar athletes.
I mean,
it was just like,
I'm just,
I just am not,
I'm not big enough to be a linebacker for the giants.
So that one's out.
Uh,
but if my life's dream was to work in baseball operations for the Yankees at a
very senior level,
of course I,
or you or any of us could have that job.
My life's dream was to run a nonprofit that has an impact on the developing
world.
Of course,
any of us could have that trouble.
So you have to suspend your disbelief and think about what you could be doing.
I need you to ask yourself which one you like best.
This exercise doesn't presuppose that the purpose of your life is to maximize
your impact purpose.
It's exercise to think about what it could be and then ask yourself what you
like.
Someone who worked for me many years ago said to me in a review,
you know,
Mike,
I just,
I don't live to work.
I work to live.
I don't think that's fair.
You're allowed to say that you're allowed to,
you're allowed to choose the first chart.
It's a,
there's no judgments here,
but you should know which one you want.
Don't say,
well,
I don't really want all that when you really do because you're afraid to try.
Nice.
That's exercise number one.
Completely unhelpful.
All this does is force an existential crisis,
so hopefully some people are nodding their heads.
Hopefully I've caused a couple of few existential crises.
Then the second part of the exercise is where you start to define,
well,
so what should I do about that?
Mike,
the last thing you said is I can be anything from an astronaut to an
entrepreneur to a,
to a politician.
So which one?
And we think about,
uh,
designing a product and the way that you design a product as you have certain
things that the product has to do and certain things that you would like it to
do and you work really hard to maximize all the things you'd like it to do and
not sacrifice any of the things that it has to do.
All right,
if we were designing an Ipod,
it's too late.
But if you were designing an Ipod,
you'd say it has to play at least a thousand songs.
It has to last at least 12 hours.
It has to fit in your pocket.
Everything else is a bonus.
And then you'd start trying to make the best product within those constraints.
So now sort of opened up the,
we've opened up the landscape,
we've zero based how we think about our life now we'd start saying,
okay,
well what I can do anything and have a big impact.
What do I want to do
here?
I did a,
it was a very simple exercise.
Make a list of things that you love to do,
things that you hate to do and things that you can not live without.
So on the last chart,
I very well may have concluded that the most impactful thing I could do,
I once studied the impact that you can have through nonprofits and one of the
highest Roi,
the highest Roi you can get.
Nonprofit work.
The time I did the research is distributing a mosquito nets in the developing
world.
The impact that it can have on malaria,
um,
and human health and is,
is,
is significant.
It doesn't mean that I necessarily have to make that my job next because when
you make this list,
like I really hate travel and hot places and mosquitoes,
so that one's just like,
might not be the right one for me.
There was other stuff on the list that can be really impactful that I can do
that I also can really enjoy.
So what do you hate doing?
Like I,
you know,
in,
in this,
these things change at different parts of your life.
I have two young kids and there are jobs out there that are just 220 days a year
on an airplane or a hotel like I won't do it.
That's a design constraint on my life.
Travel some during the quarter,
but it can't.
I can't live on the road.
I'll miss what's going on at home.
It's a personal choice.
You fill this whole thing in and you have to do it.
Really honestly,
you have to be honest with yourself,
and I'll use one example where we never are,
and again,
another really personal question,
but it's money.
How much money do you need to be happy?
Well,
we've all been trained to answer that question,
right?
We've been trained by Shel Silverstein poems that what you're supposed to say is
the money doesn't matter.
You've money cannot buy happiness.
I don't care about money.
All right,
you were living in sixth floor studio,
welcome,
but two kids.
It's hard.
There are tradeoffs and there are considerations that we have to make an all of
these things.
So take this one.
Let's use this example.
How much money to someone new because he get tricked on both ends.
What happens is there will be a day,
a moment where you have an opportunity to choose among jobs.
They may be within your company or they may be outside of your company and
here's how they always look.
There's this thing that you know you want to be doing and it's really cool.
It doesn't pay as much,
but you can live,
it's fine,
you can live on it and there's this other thing and then they keep raising the
temperature and offering you more and more and more money not to do the thing
you really want to do.
It's a real choice.
Everyone does the same thing.
Everyone takes the money,
but we never ever say no one ever says,
I'm going to sacrifice my dream to take the money.
Our brains are too good at self justification.
We never ever do that.
When we say is,
I'll take the money now and then in two or three years I can do anything I want.
Here's what happens.
Whatever money you make you spend,
trust me.
Whatever money you make you spend.
So if someone says to you,
Hey,
come take a job that is inconsistent with the impact you want to have.
It's inconsistent with the things you enjoy,
but we'll pay you a ton of money.
What will happen is you will spend it and then you will not only be unhappy,
you'll have even less flexibility in your life because now you have a house in
Montauk,
which is great.
You used to have a job you liked and you read it a place in [inaudible].
Now I have a job you hate and you own a house in Montauk and you have to keep
the job.
These personal sort of design constraints and design considerations,
you have to really like fight with yourself and wrestle with each and every one
of them
and then you start to come to a picture.
You've,
you started to outline some things that could be impactful that you'd really
love to do.
You start to outline things that you would enjoy and things that you would not
enjoy and you start to get a sense for something like what you'd want to do at
this stage of the exercise.
I could probably say I love working with great people and leading great people.
I love working in a technology related sector and I love that.
I love to have work that impact lots and lots and lots of users and a positive
way that's vague.
Like I you can't next,
you can't add a objective to your resume based on that.
But I get closer.
Next exercise.
Oh,
and the last part of that is I take Steph Landon this point,
look at the credit card statements,
look at how much money we spend every month,
add up how much private schools cost and the mortgage it does at that.
And it adds up to this much money.
And I'm like,
okay,
that's,
I need that.
I got to make that much money at any amount of money over that.
Forget it.
I won't,
I literally don't care.
I am not going to chase more.
I just need to hit,
I need to hit a certain bid.
Cause if I donate this bid,
the next best school in our district after the private school has a metal
detector.
So I'm going to be right.
I'm going to Atlanta right there.
All right,
so then we're narrowing the field.
We're designing this product that is your life,
so now I'm just going to filter the results.
Geography,
function,
industry,
company size.
Where do I want to live?
There were essentially two choices,
New York or someplace else.
For me,
it depends on what is important for you,
but there was a period of my life where I didn't,
I didn't internalize this and some would call and say,
we've got this awesome job for you running six countries in Europe
and I am not a Europe guy.
You guys,
you know me,
like I'm not supposed to be there.
But you go through this crazy like,
oh,
maybe I should go to Europe and I can sell widgets to French people and things
will be great.
And then thinking of the career I could have,
because I can put global experience on my resume when I leave New York to go on
vacation,
I'm sad I can't wait to get home.
I love New York.
That's my design constraint.
I have friends.
You feel that way about Chicago who feel the way about California?
Who,
who will not mess with Texas.
That's up to you.
Other people do not have this constraint.
I means you can do way more.
I have friends who will pick up stakes and go anytime you have to know the
answer for you and the job shouldn't decide that you should decide that and then
filter the jobs before they interrupt your day.
Next is function.
Should you do,
and this is,
you know a lot of us,
you sorta take a job coming out of business school or something and that's your
function and in years at the,
it does in the function.
You all work at a great company that it's this let you switch a lot of places
it's harder.
There are basically three functions in any company.
We make it so difficult like we we,
we make it sound difficult.
You can either make this stuff or you can sell the stuff or you get support.
The people who make the stuff or sell to stuff,
those are basically the three jobs.
So which one are you going to do?
You gonna make it,
are you going to sell it?
Are you going to support?
And then is that marketing,
is that finance?
Is that legal?
You don't have to stay in the function forever,
but it's really healthy once you start to now the field and say I enjoy blank,
I enjoy design,
I enjoyed sales and if you have a hard time with it,
it's hard to say.
It's especially hard to say when you're in the job cause whatever job you're in
kind of sucks today and that's life because the job you're in today comes with
email and meetings and a forum you have to fill out and an angry customer like
it's just,
it always looks better to be in someone else's job.
So you ask yourself what are the things that like stir my animal spirits
wouldn't.
When am I,
what am I most psyched at work?
Is it when you are organizing this stuff,
there are people who get endorphins when they are in spreadsheets.
Taking chaos and turning that chaos into order,
giving that order back to the team and helping that team to run better.
That feels good.
And have you ever seen the sweat away?
The sweaters are lined up in my closet.
It is like is the closet of a psychopath.
I love when the comp plan matches the behaviors you want for the team.
That is fun for me.
That is a thing that like I get endorphins from that.
Other people,
they just see the like let a Google spreadsheet has been open on their computer
and like Ah,
they,
they don't want to do it.
Some people,
the thought of going on a sales call and convincing someone to take something
that you want to give them makes them want to throw up.
Some of us walk out of a meeting where we've influenced someone and we're
completely energized by it.
So what are those things at work it's not,
do I love the job that I currently have in finance and I love the job I
currently have in sales,
but now like every day it sucks in one way or another.
But what is the essence of the thing that I love doing?
Leading,
influencing others,
organizing the world,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Then helps to narrow down the functions.
Then you can ask industry.
Some people have a strong opinion on this.
You probably should pick.
It gets harder and harder to switch over time.
You guys all picked a pretty good one.
I mean it's skip this.
You work in a good industry and you could switch to food services.
We have a passion for it,
but this like,
I think you're right,
like you're on the right path and then Lazarus sort of company size and company
stage and a mistake that many people who work at big,
successful companies make is that your lens for the world starts to become big
successful companies.
When I worked at Google,
it was a while ago,
there were only three jobs.
It was Google,
Facebook and whatever was the other hot company people were talking about.
That's going to become the next Google or Facebook.
That's all we talked about.
There is this enormous range of companies of different sizes and different
stages at which one could work.
Now the more enlightened among us thought that there was Google,
Facebook,
the place,
it could be the next Google or Facebook and some startup that called and said
there was a fourth in between our companies with a market cap between $200
million and $20 billion that need really good people.
And you know,
I've had friends who were like,
what I really want to do is just run a big function and I'm like,
you work at a this one or another one,
a really big company where someone might not give you a really big function,
but there's another company with a thousand employees,
5,000 employees,
but the sun would rise and set on someone with your talents.
This is an important consideration and it's one that many of us miss because I
don't know anyone here ever think about working in like open table or grub hub
or TripAdvisor or homeaway.
I mean these are companies with market caps of like a billion,
2 billion,
$3 billion or so small like Google deltas,
$3 billion.
Sort of a work at a company with a whole thing is worth that.
It's like,
Oh God,
that's a really cool companies that deliver really cool services that could
really use great people.
I'm not going to be clear,
I'm not asking anybody here to go take a job like that,
but I'm just saying that there's a range of company sizes and whatever company
you work at,
you tend not to see the other ones you ever like.
Start up.
People are their startup people.
Like all my startups getting too big.
I need a new startup.
Okay,
as long as that's not because you know where you sit is where you stand.
You just have started to form this bias.
If you really love it,
then that's the right thing for you and then their stage.
Continuing excellence is the stage of many large companies that can be fun.
Turnaround can be a lot of fun.
It takes somebody who's broken company and fix it.
Startup can be a lot of fun.
You change the paper in the copier.
It's up to you.
You got to decide what you like doing.
I have friends in the harvest business.
Everyone is no fun.
They're like,
okay.
The investors think the business.
The last five more years.
If we can make it last eight we'll make a lot of money.
Well,
but that's a job.
It's an honorable job.
It helps me to keep the economy moving.
You've got to make your own decisions.
So do that exercise.
You start to narrow down,
right?
What are the things that could have impact?
How can I be important to the world?
How important do I want to be?
What are the things that I enjoy or don't enjoy or things that I need to be
happy.
And then as I'm picking among career choices,
which are the ones that feel right to me and you start to narrow the field.
So I overtime I was able to narrow the field down to I really like tech.
I want a smaller company,
but one with,
uh,
you know who that is an opportunity to have real impact.
I want something to see that,
that,
that I think we can really grow and I want to be in a significant leadership
position like my then,
then you can wait for your pitch and you know when to,
because you've got a good sense for that thing that you're looking for.
Um,
if you look at the,
if you look at the careers of people who've been successful,
when people who haven't,
generally speaking,
the people who've been successful have known what they're looking for and they
have a plan.
The people who haven't,
people who've done okay tend to have a career path that has a lot of variety or
no variety,
right?
They like stay in one job in one function and just wait to be elevated.
Or they keep changing to try new things,
but you don't see a plan.
And so the next part I would suggest is once you've got a sense for what you
want to do,
you then come to grips with the brutal facts that you are unqualified for that
thing that you want completely unqualified to do it today.
But you have the ability and the right to expect to be in that position in some
period of time and then from here to there you have to make a plan the way you
make a plan.
Here's one way you can do it.
Think of the job that you really want.
If mine,
if mine got really specific,
I say I want to be a,
I want to be a senior executive,
a c level executive in the tech space with consumer facing products.
Let's say I pick that one.
There are bio's of senior executives in the tech space available on every one of
those companies' websites.
Read them what?
What experiences did they have?
Meet with people who have these jobs.
Ask them,
what do you have to be good at in your job?
You'd be amazed at who is willing to talk to you.
Then you say,
okay,
those are experiences I need.
Those are things I need to be good at.
How do I get it?
Some of them are easy.
You need to know how to manage a PNL.
You need to know how to read the numbers for the job.
I just described.
I got this,
my wife was a beggar.
She gave me a book.
It was like this thick and it was on accounting and finance and I've read this
horrible book.
I'd rather eat that book,
then read it again.
But then I knew you know what to debit and what the credit and the difference
between Ebit and Ebitda and all these things that are so confusing to someone
who hasn't read the book.
I read the book,
you basically get it.
There are other things that reading the book health,
so you really have to do it.
Managing a large team.
Anyone who has the big a big job,
like the one I described manages a large team at the time that I did this impact
map exercise.
Uh,
I manage a team of one intern.
His name was Felix.
I was not qualified to manage managers and a large team and organization.
Tell me about your leadership experience like,
well,
one time Felix wasn't doing what he should and I said,
Felix,
I really need you to do something different,
but what you can do with any of these capabilities as you can disambiguate you,
break it down into its atomic parts,
right,
and okay,
what does,
what does leading a large team entail?
Being able to hire good people.
Okay.
Break that down further because if you don't have a team,
you're not allowed to hire.
Knowing how to identify how to recruit and identify good,
good talent.
Okay?
Anyone here can participate in that?
If you are an individual contributor on a team that hires from time to time,
ask your manager if you can help be a part of the interview process.
Tell your manager,
I've just read two books on the topic.
Read the books.
I think I've developed some expertise on interviewing.
Can I please interview a candidate and give you my notes on the person and
compare with you.
Don't take you very little bit of time.
Now you're becoming someone who's developing expertise in interviewing.
Next,
you get a Felix and you manage that.
Felix.
Well,
you make breakdown other elements of a leader's position being a good
communicator.
There are books on this and there are opportunities for you to demonstrate this
at work.
You practice these things.
The worst thing that could ever happen is you get the job of your dreams and
you're just,
and you just never put in the effort to become good at those things.
You swing and miss when you finally get the chance.
So that's career roadmap.
You break the job that you'd like to have ultimately in your life down into the
things that you have to be good at and the experiences you need.
And you go and you get them,
you go develop those experiences.
Sometimes the books you're mentoring,
your practice,
your side hustle.
It's up to you.
Don't we on time?
Do we have any time left?
I think we do,
but what I want when I want to do is the next part is a little different.
So I'm gonna pause there and take questions.
Was a question.
Is this helpful,
useful?
There's a question.
How often do you find that people are just,
he please use the microphone?
No,
it's okay.
I'll just repeat the question.
If you say,
uh,
how often do you find that people are just always striving for the grass,
always being greener,
seeing something better than what they currently have when it turns out they're
just looking for something else different as opposed to this specific thing.
How often do you find that someone is just looking for the next thing and the
grass is always greener rather than looking for the right thing?
Always.
All the time.
It's a great question and it's why having a purpose and a plan is so important
to your success and I want to,
if I cannot wait,
I want to sort of break that question down into two parts because one is just
vague.
Dissatisfaction as a,
as a driver of a career,
it is not necessarily going to get you to the right place.
You don't know where you're at is obvious,
right?
But he don't know where you're going.
The faster you run in that direction,
the more likely you are to
Mr.
The second component of that question.
So have a plan.
So part of the answers,
if you have a plan and you're jamming to achieve that plan,
you're on the right path.
Second part of the question is
you might have acid or I might say,
Hey,
I'm really ambitious so I'm always miserable because other people are more
senior than me or more successful.
Have you ever feel that somebody's ever like leave your team or leave the
company and go somewhere else and get a better job and better titling?
You're like,
ah,
that person please.
The guy is terrible.
Like there's someplace you want to be and an other people seem to be someplace
else and you're not and it makes you like,
ah,
crazy.
So
that's not healthy either.
Right?
Not being ambitious is not healthy.
Not having a plan is not healthy,
but then always being miserable because you want to be somewhere else.
It's not healthy to.
So
as you think about it,
here's a good exercise to do.
Imagine the sum of all of your dreams,
astronaut,
like whatever it is you want to be CEO of.
Pick a company or you want to run such and such.
Just pick it.
And if you wanted a ton of money,
give yourself 100 million bucks,
put it all in a pile,
put it on a pile on a plate and I will give it to you.
It's a trade that you have to make.
I will trade you something.
I will give you all the things you want and all you have to give me back is
the health of someone important to you.
Yeah.
Or your site or your limbs,
your relationship with your parents.
Very few people would make that trade,
which means you currently have this,
a mathematic,
mathematically true.
You currently have more value than all the things to which you aspire.
We have right now is worth more than all of the things that you want.
So it would be criminal.
It'd be horrible to have all of that and be miserable all the time because
somebody else got a raise.
You didn't know a promotion,
you didn't.
It'd be awful to go to set yourself off on this journey to have impact,
but all along the way to be miserable because you haven't had the impact yet.
So I don't know the balance.
The trick and it's hard to do.
It's to enjoy today and be gentle and be driving for greater impact that you
want to have in the future.
A great way to do that.
One man's opinion,
take it for what it's worth,
is just don't multitask.
If you're with your friends,
turn off your phone,
right?
Like yes,
there's interesting stuff going on on your phone,
but there's more,
there's interesting stuff going on with your friends too,
and if you're half on the phone,
you missed the whole thing.
Yes,
someone else got promoted or something's going on at work and stressing you out,
but be in the moment that you're in now.
Don't be stressing out about some stuff going on over there.
That's a,
that's a balance and it's a balance.
It's a,
it's a great question though.
Thank you.
Other questions in the back?
So as you're going through these exercises,
identifying what you need in order to set up the filters to build a plan,
what,
how do you,
or what recommendations do you have for someone that says,
I don't know.
I don't know what I would,
the question is if you're going through all this and don't know what should you
do,
this is the tyranny of choice,
right?
This is what's so hard.
There was some experiment where they um,
psychologist gave,
they brought a group people instead they get to have a free pair of jeans and
they said to the one group,
they're like,
just pick a pair of jeans.
They had three genes.
It's like tidy genes and regular jeans and baggy jeans and
everyone under 30 I guess took the tidy genius.
They had another group come in and they were like,
we have 60 different kinds of genes at every different kind of you want.
And later they ask people how happy they were with them and the people who had
fewer choices were happier.
People,
had more choices,
had all this like regret over whether or not they took the right ones.
So if your question is do you go through this whole exercise and you're just
paralyzed by the choice,
paralyzed,
give yourself a deadline and give yourself a method.
All right.
I did a thing where I woke up every morning at 5:00 AM and I would write,
I would write and write and write.
I wrote a bucket list.
I wrote a eulogy.
I wrote the book report that I would want my granddaughter to write about me
some 50 years from now.
Right,
right,
right.
All these things that I want to be true like style.
You know what?
What do you want it to say in your eulogy?
Like Steve Leaves us at 125 years old.
He still has all of his hair and he's 90 wonderful,
great,
great grandchildren.
Whatever your thing is,
like what?
What are those things that are important?
The more you go through that exercise,
the more clarity it gives you,
and I can't emphasize this enough.
Writing is really powerful,
not typing,
writing.
It just seems to touch a different part of your brain and that exercise.
Exercise starts to bring you clarity and then wander the earth.
Tell you something.
I'm going to go talk to these 10 people who have careers,
different kinds of careers that they seem to enjoy it.
I'm just going to ask them,
how'd you do it?
What was interesting?
What did you like do that exercise.
If you still don't know what to do,
that means you're indifferent.
Pick one,
pick one and stick with it and just go for pick one.
That's like an honestly,
there is no perfect answer for you unless you are Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart,
you are supposed to play piano like 99 point 900900900 9% of us are not supposed
to do anything,
so pick one.
I have a friend who's an author and I sent him,
I was like,
ah,
this is a couple of years ago,
so it gets us so great.
You wrote a book like you're a writer,
how did you know you are a writer?
And he,
he was like,
this is stupidest question I've ever heard.
You're a writer after you write a book so you don't know you're a writer and
see,
write a book.
Then you were right or I'm like,
no,
but like a real writer.
He's like,
they don't do that.
They don't split them into categories.
There's just the writer.
So if you can't pick,
I don't know,
even my,
I put my email before,
just email me.
I'll,
I'll give you some.
So
never
things change,
opportunities come up and are too busy planning or you're this what,
what's your perspective?
The question if you didn't hear it was um,
I think the opposite of everything you just said
that,
what was your name?
Matt?
So Matt said,
I've gotten advice that you shouldn't try to over engineer your career cause you
could miss something.
It's very good advice,
but I would,
uh,
but I might express it differently.
You should be iterating this plan regularly.
You should regularly be asking yourself what kind of impact do I want to have?
What kind of a career road,
what career road mapped I want to execute.
As you're in the field,
as you're doing and learning,
you should be iterating that plan.
There's,
you know,
there was some moment when a bunch of people who really wanted to work in media
defined it as television and missed Internet,
did not reboot their career plan for,
maybe I'll do something in the internet much to the
much to their dismay.
So I would say you should have a plan and you should engineer it,
but you should in the same way that we develop products and put them in front of
our users,
you should launch early and often I should learn from the experience,
we should iterate to the next,
the next level of the product.
And I think that gives you the best of both.
It gives you a plan.
You're not just wandering in the wilderness and it allows you to take new data
points and incorporate them into that plan.
That would be,
that'd be my advice.
But every,
everybody's got a,
um,
everybody's gotta do their own thing.
The,
the chairman of Linkedin wrote a book,
uh,
which is very good.
It's very popular.
And it basically just says,
hang out with really smart,
interesting people and some good shit will happen.
And that's a like,
and he has a lot more money than me.
So you gotta so you pick like there are there,
there,
there are different ways to execute it.
My humble advice would be have a plan and consistently edit that plan and
iterate that plan as you learn more.
Nick's,
so,
uh,
um,
some of this sometimes,
and I think you were alluding to,
it's in games,
big fish,
small pond,
small fish,
big pond,
sort of,
uh,
sort of general happiness too.
Is there,
is there a preference to you Peter,
and then do you think there's a core small pilot environment?
Elliot asked what's better to be a big fish in a small pond or a small fish in a
big pond and it is completely dependent upon what you enjoy?
Um,
big fish,
small pond
as my job now,
my,
my company has 800 employees.
Um,
I make a decision and we do it.
And actually I remember when I first took the job,
um,
I said to my CFO,
there was a company we wanted to buy it.
I was like,
okay,
like,
you know,
I was like,
what was winter?
Like?
Who,
who do we have to talk to now?
And she was like,
nobody,
you're the CEO,
you just buy it.
Whoa.
I guess this is what I signed up for at the same time.
And the job,
you know,
I had a job I had had previously.
The only way to get anything done was to build coalitions and get everybody on
the same page and manage stakeholders.
Some people are really good at one of those.
Some people are good at the other,
some enjoy one,
some enjoy the other.
That's for me,
that's essentially what determines,
um,
bigger company versus a bigger company versus a smaller company.
I'd also,
I would just call,
I'd also comment that it's a false choice because,
you know,
there are people,
I mean this is a big company,
right?
But there's a small group working on the Google space elevator or whatever you
guys are up to that I'm sure it doesn't feel like a big company over there,
right.
Was probably like 10 engineers and a product guy and a marketer like just trying
to launch it into space.
So it's not,
it's not only company,
it's sort of its team and its,
um,
remit and it's how much that thing is the same as everything else going on at
the company or how much it's unique.
The more it's the same,
the more your skill set has to be bureaucratic in nature and the more it's
different,
the more your skill set has to be getting things done in nature,
let's say.
Thank you.
Elliot.
Can you talk more about living below your means and how this plays into the
decisions you're talking about?
You mentioned renting and quality,
now you own Montauk.
Can you explain a little bit more,
you know,
live through Billy,
like how that impacts
the question was,
can you talk about,
it's a good question.
Living below your means and how that can create optionality,
I think that creates optionality.
It gives you flexibility in your career.
I have never successfully done it yet.
And there are people who go on CNBC and they'll tell you like the way to become
a millionaire is you just stop having a latte every day at Starbucks and then
over time the interest compounds and you'll be a millionaire.
I've met millionaires.
None.
No one has ever said to me,
I just stopped drinking lattes
and Al bloated.
It's um,
it's good to be a saver.
It's good to live below your means.
People who do that are better people than I am.
What I have found instead is that whatever you make,
you spend.
And I,
um,
and therefore to the earlier point,
I figure out what we really need at this moment in time in our family to be
happy and then how much we need to sort of save for retirement and the kids'
school and all that stuff.
You add it up and that's the amount of money I need to make and I'm painfully
aware of if we make any more,
you're just going to get an extra bedroom on the apartment or something.
Right?
Like it's,
it's,
it's going to in my life.
Is this going to get spent?
And I also know that that extra bedroom of the apartment is not happiness,
not living the career and the life with a purpose that is meaningful to me is
happiness.
And I also,
I have friends who have successfully gone this way too.
They have just said,
look,
we spend too much money.
It's not worth it.
Let's just like,
let's get down to the basics of what we need so that we can be happier.
And that's fair too.
I don't know that I could successfully pull that off either.
Um,
it just feels to me like the spending becomes somewhat permanent and so in a
weird way,
my advices know what that number is.
Make it disregard any more that you make and understand that if you do make it
and you save it,
you're a really good person.
But it'd be spend it,
I feel you.
I've been there.
Okay.
I'll come right back to you a little bit more about
your roadmap as it related to,
so my roadmap and the decisions I made after leaving Google ob,
I had a terrific job and worked with great people at Google.
My,
my,
my job over time became more bureaucratic,
which wasn't for me.
And also there is a point at which,
um,
you might feel in your career,
this sort of flattening of either what you're learning or just this sort of,
the trajectory of your career in the current path that you're on.
And someone called me with an opportunity to be the CEO of a,
basically something that was being built from scratch and checked a bunch of
boxes for me
and it was the absolute wrong one.
It was,
uh,
it was a catastrophe catastrophe.
But in doing it,
I got to really for the first time in the wild be a CEO and I absolutely loved
it and I learned a ton.
Um,
and it went well.
Operationally was working or issue is sort of investor relations related,
but it was operational,
it was working.
And I was like,
I think I can do this job.
And the next thing that presented itself was even better.
Um,
it's where,
and it's,
it's where I am now.
So in a way,
I mean,
this is a personal anecdote and I don't know what it's worth,
but I made a mistake when I made a change,
but the bigger mistake would have been not making a change optimally,
I would have left for something that was a success and a catastrophe right out
of the gate and save two years of my life,
that would have been optimal.
But the next best option was just forward progress.
I can't emphasize how important doing is to success.
And it sounds,
it sounds so obvious,
but I have a,
but I have a story about a friend of some of ours at one point,
remember when Yahoo Bought Tumblr?
I don't know why he was,
he was possessed with the eye.
The cute started blogging about that this was a bad deal.
I was like,
who cares?
But this,
our friend really cared to blogging and blogging about how this was a,
that this was a bad deal for Yahoo.
And then he paints some people on Twitter.
He's like,
what do you think about all the things I've been writing about?
What a bad deal this is?
And people tweeted about it and so on.
And then Bloomberg television called him and asked if he'd come on as an expert
to talk about this deal.
Everyone is looking for someone who knows what they're talking about and knows
what they're doing and no one does.
So if you just act like you do,
you eventually get this shit you're after.
So forward.
Motion is just really,
it's,
it's really important and I don't know,
for whatever that's worth,
that was,
that's my life.
I wouldn't do it.
There were some of those,
go ahead.
Okay.
So my question was about
kind of what you do,
but sometimes you know,
any filters,
maybe you say,
I don't want to live anywhere else,
but you aren't,
but then I need a good opportunity because it's like,
how do you think about [inaudible] to me
the question was how do you think about temporary sacrifices in your design
principles to move your career ahead more quickly?
It's really important to know which of your design principles are constraints
versus desires.
And if,
um,
so for me a constraint is the time I needed to spend with my children.
So I won't,
there are jobs that for two years I just want to see them,
but it's only two years.
But they'll,
they'll,
they'll never be this age again.
So for me,
I just,
that one I won't budge on.
I won't budge on it at all.
There's other stuff that you know,
most people are not as psycho as I am about wanting to live in New York,
like they'll take it,
but they'd also moved to California for the right deal.
She's up to know which ones for you are fixed constraints and which ones are are
negotiable and the fixed constraints don't even think about it like you.
You made a principal decision with clear eyes and then something came along and
tried to get you to think differently.
At one point in my career,
I just said,
you know what?
I'm not going to play golf like I'm just not.
Everyone gets tried to pressure me to play golf.
Oh,
business gets done in the golf course.
You have to play golf.
We're going on a golf trip.
No,
I hate golf.
I'm not doing it.
It's so liberating.
It's liberating.
Now every time someone's like,
oh,
hey,
we're putting this thing together.
There's golf.
I'm like,
nope,
not doing it.
You've got to decide what those fixed constraints are for you.
The questions,
I love it.
This approach is very good questions to ask Adam mentors and advisors to get the
best advice from that.
What are the
best questions to ask of mentors and advisors to get the best advice for them?
Um,
there's a book called the finer points of leadership that's a good read and
there's a code,
there's a concept in there called the career covenant and the Covenant is you
agree with your manager.
Then I'm going to do really good work for you and help make you as my manager is
successful.
What I'd like from you is advice and I'm championing championing my career.
Would you be willing to do that with me?
Any manager worth her salt will say yes.
Then in a with a manager like that,
you've you,
you've negotiated that we're going to be talking about my career from time to
time and then you can just ask anything.
Yeah,
I asked for feedback.
A great way to ask for feedback.
Everybody in this room like you go to,
you go to the tech talks for like you're probably winning,
you're probably getting good scores.
Your feedback is usually you're doing a great job.
So that was a managing director.
What would I have done differently with this project?
Well,
I mean,
you're not a managing director.
I'm not asking you to make me a managing director.
What's the difference between me and a managing director?
Well,
you would have asked so many annoying questions.
That's fair.
That's helpful.
Tell me what I could have done.
Not Ask somebody annoying questions and on and on and on.
So I think forcing feedback on yourself that is not just,
did I do a good job,
help me make me feel good about the job.
It just did.
But okay,
people are much better than me.
What would they have done different?
Gets you that kind of feedback that can really fuel your career.
And then I think with people who you don't know as well,
people who were in other jobs,
other professions,
when you meet people,
just be so vulnerable and willing for them to know that you don't know what
they're talking about and keep,
keep,
keep asking them questions.
So you're at some like,
you know,
my wife and me.
So you go to these fancy dinners and you'd have to meet random people.
This is terrible is my life.
And so you're like,
Hey,
what do you do Tom?
And Tom's like,
oh,
I work in debt capital markets for Goldman Sachs.
And I'm like,
what?
Everyone says,
they're like,
oh cool.
That capital markets,
how's that capital market's going this year?
I say,
what's the capital markets?
Which is,
it's embarrassing,
right?
I live in and how long have I lived in New York?
How could I not know what to capital market?
So,
so tell me what is,
I don't work in finance.
What is that?
Capital Markets.
We create liquidity for investment grade companies.
What's liquidity?
For some reason people describe their jobs in a way that makes it sound so
complicated.
And when you keep asking,
they finally give up and they say,
we loan money to Ge.
When I say,
I say,
oh,
that's brilliant.
I said,
Ge makes a lot of money.
Why would they need to borrow money?
He says,
honestly,
these days it's just to buy back their stock.
It's financial engineering.
And then I go,
how does that work?
And then they explain it to you and I'm like,
what do you have to do to be good at that job?
Ge can borrow money from anyone.
They have great credit.
Why would they borrow it from you?
He says,
well that's all sales.
Tell me how you win in sales.
For me it's a relationship game.
I take the guys out but blah,
blah blah and I know more about the market.
How do you know more about the organ?
It is like anybody else have a five year old.
I have a five year old,
I am the five year old of asking you about your career.
Why?
Why did you that?
What does that mean?
What's the opposite of apple that that that that like on and on and on.
I just keep going until I really know what this person does and I can really
engage them in a discussion and I've taken something from it.
Or until they just like they surrender and one way they surrenders,
they go,
what do you do to try to make you stop?
The other is they drink their drink really fast and they're like,
oh my drinks have to have to go to the bar.
That's all right.
The people who stay with you,
these are people that you're now familiar with.
Next time you see them,
like I'm not like,
hey Tom from debt markets,
how are you?
I'm like,
Tom,
I just heard interest rates moved and I remember what you told me about what
that means for liquidity.
Are People still buying back stock?
And he's like,
you're not gonna believe it.
Nobody's buying back stock where it's 10% to goal this year we're getting
killed.
Like I'm having a conversation with Tom.
So you're talking to a mentor,
someone in an industry that you like,
just ask questions like,
uh,
I don't know,
like a five year old.
There's gotta be a better way to that,
but ask questions like a five year old.
We had a couple of minutes left.
Anyone else?
[inaudible]
next question was time management,
but people have a meeting next.
I'll pause for a second.
Anybody needs to go,
go and I'll stay and answer the time management question.
Even if you don't stay and to,
so we'll give it a minute.
Thank you guys for coming.
It was great.
[inaudible]
next page is time man.
How much time you got?
I'll give you,
I'll give you like the three minute version and then if you want to ask more,
but you guys are welcome to leave as you want to leave.
So
you're working hard and you have obligations.
You have family.
Some of you are in an adult kickball league,
like there's just no timeline,
right?
So how do you also work a career plan and meet with mentors and read books on
accounting and all that stuff if you,
um,
so you have to be hyper productive.
And if you calculate the number of hours that are already spoken for in your
life,
you have sleep eight hours,
you have to sleep it.
Ours don't believe anyone who tells you otherwise.
You must sleep eight hours.
You have to exercise an hour a day.
You have to,
you really should.
You have to bathe,
you have to eat.
And if you're ambitious,
you work 60 hours a week,
which over seven days averages out to,
you know,
call it eight hours,
eight and a half hours a day.
You add that all up.
You have fun on an average day blending weekends and weekdays you have five
hours of discretionary time every day you have five hours to live.
That's your time to proactively decide how you are going to spend it and what
you're going to achieve with your life.
The average American spends five hours a day on social media and television and
then they all say,
I have no time
if
and the bell tolls for you for five hours.
You could be doing anything you want,
anything you want.
You could put more hours into your work so you don't work 60 hours,
you work 70 there have been points in my career while it's been 80 you decide
when that's appropriate.
If you have kids,
you oh time to your kids.
I love my children.
Five hours every night is a lot a lot to gets you there.
You have time with friends.
You spend a proactively,
you decide how you're going to invest those five hours,
a portion of those five hours.
I invest in personal development almost everyday,
right?
Reading.
There's a list of things that I know I want to read and I know I want to learn.
Um,
spending time with people in the space who can give you perspective,
et Cetera.
A proactive investment of that time.
If you believe the 10,000 hour rule with five every day and just a few years,
you could also be a concert pianist.
This is up to you.
Five hours is a ton of time,
but most of us don't invest it proactively.
It gets invested for us.
We work,
get up.
You're like,
shit,
what am I doing today?
All right.
He scrambled.
He like,
I'm not going to go to gym now.
Go after work.
You work,
somebody bothers you and then it's six and you've got to get home and then you
didn't go to the gym and you're home and you scramble it.
The kids and he would just beat and you're like,
all right,
I know I have some work to do about it.
Like all of this veg out for a minute and next thing you know Netflix is saying
to you,
are you still there?
Does that ever happened to you get a life.
Of course I'm still here.
I have found that when I proactively say,
Hey,
I want to spend my time and then put it in my calendar that it works and you
calendars is really powerful operating system.
You never miss a one on one with your manager because it's in your calendar and
you go and yet somehow like we keep not going to the gym.
It's in my calendar when I read is in my calendar.
When I get in bed it's in my calendar.
It's really weird
but it is really effective.
There's this block of time on Saturday that is my personal time now with my
family and it's not work related.
It's investment in things I want to learn,
explore or contribute like it's my time,
5:00 AM to about 10:00 AM that's mine.
Here's this block of time where going to be me with the kids and I will not
check an email.
I cannot be bothered.
I'm going to be with my kids.
It's dedicated time and it's so much more powerful and you wake up on Saturday
and you're like,
all right,
what are we going to do?
So the most
passionate advice I could give you on this topic is to proactively schedule your
five hours.
I can also tell you,
um,
and I said this in passing,
but like when you sleep,
you really are much more productive.
They did a,
uh,
an experiment.
People were asked to sleep six hours a night for two weeks and they performed
cognitively and physically at the same level of people who had pulled back to
back all nighters.
When you don't sleep,
you suck at everything.
And we're all ambitious.
And so we're looking for an extra hour in an extra hour and you take it out of
sleep and it's a,
it's massively destructive to your ability to be productive.
So the way to do it,
I said before,
like I literally have an alarm that goes off that tells me it's time to get in
bed and I have to plug my phone and not by my bed.
Because if I bring my phone to the bed,
then I will lay in the bed with the phone for another hour.
The phone is actually over by the door next to my gym clothes.
And when the alarm goes off,
I get up,
I get out of bed,
I go,
I grabbed the phone and I'm right there with my gym clothes.
So I know I have to go to the gym now.
Like you can create these barriers or these guardrails in your life that force
you to proactively and intelligently invest your time and the things that
maximize your productivity.
Other questions?
Oh,
so this was if we had enough time,
essentially
quickly,
the way to manage your to do's is to figure out what's the goal you're trying to
achieve?
How much impact can this action item have?
How fast can you do it and by when is it due?
And we tend to,
we have a tendency to go to a meeting and some to do's come up and they go to
the top of the list.
And my advice is you will never do everything on your list.
So always assess every to do and only do the high leverage ones that you can
first,
the ones that you can do quickly that are due soon.
And then the high leverage ones that take a long time and match them to the
amount of time that you have.
So you know,
like you have 15 minutes between meetings,
so you come back to your desk and you open an email and it's like a 20 page
PowerPoint you're supposed to read and then you read like four pages of it.
But then yeah,
the 15 minutes are up.
So then you run to the meeting and then you come back and you're like,
okay,
let me go to my email.
And you're like,
oh,
this PowerPoint,
where was I?
And you start to basically start over,
not matching.
The important task to the amount of time with which you can use to get it done
is the way that most people make themselves unproductive.
Nope,
it was really nice to see you guys.
This is a lot of fun.
So I'll put my,
this is how to get in touch with me if you want.
I'm more than happy to help is great to see you.
You're all friends or friends of friends and I'm
at your disposal if I can ever be useful to you.
Thanks,
you guys.